around us we have companies that helping
cancer treatment and they use the
platform and you see how they
advance they researched and how they
managed to
to overcome all their own expectation
with
this explainability they managed to
extract from the platform together with
other companies that's running on
autonomous vehicle and you've got to
feel that you're part of their project
right they're sharing with us the result
they're sharing you guys the
incredibles the incredible
uh
use cases and and insights they managed
to get and you feel so
given you this sense of of duty and and
purpose
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel
j impact
leap
google for startups and hippo and in
media partnership with ctec
hello hello and welcome to another
awesome episode of 20 minute leaders i'm
really excited about this one this is a
company that i'm personally invested in
but the story is so cool about how they
use deep learning to
meaningfully impact research teams and
of course i'm objectively biased but i
still think this is such a cool company
and specifically we're going to be
talking to you thomas real the chief
technology officer yotam is an expert in
machine and deep learning with 10 years
of experience in these fields he's been
involved in massive military projects in
the field of underground warfare and
later on joined select nuclear research
center as a key developer in machine
learning projects
following his army service jotum
developed and led ai and big data
projects from research to production for
a few startups and acted as a
professional consultant to companies
developing ai technologies his expertise
includes image and video recognition nlp
i'll go trading and signal analysis your
time is an auto deduct with strong
leadership qualities and great
communication skills
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
very very much for being here how are
you
i'm great i'm great thank you for having
me it looks like an amazing project i
look forward to
get here with you i appreciate that very
very much your time we've known each
other for a while um i may personally
also invested in in the company that and
that you're helping run tensor leap
looking at deep learning but while this
conversation will also
have components of tensor leap inside
what i'm really curious about is to hear
your own journey and to hear some of the
bigger pain points that you've
identified in the research arena and you
know we're all aware that the machine
learning and deep learning tools are
taking over the world by storm if
software was eating the world then ai is
is really transforming it in in
unprecedented ways and the process and
the progress to to create a lot of these
models and to fine-tune them is not that
trivial and that's exactly the space
that you're coming in and so obviously
the work that you've dedicated yourself
to um
lends itself to have a dramatic impact
on organizations that later on make a
large impact later on so that's enough
from me but yo tom tell me a little bit
about about yourself and and some of the
things that you're really excited about
myself well
uh i started my january in science
way back like 10 12 years ago in a very
small desert city
in the south of israel
um
i started around physics uh i got
familiar with uh
with the science area
after some
inspiring school teacher
got me into some open uh lectures in the
ben gurion university
i got there
the first time i saw some professor
lecturing about his own research and i
understood that it's gonna be i saw like
i saw how inspired you were towards the
research you've been
yeah so so so going back to a little bit
about you know your upbringing and what
what got you so excited about this space
and about the space of neural networks
well listen our network spaces is
amazing you can see the things that
people doing with it we're pushing the
limits of
what's possible every day a bit more
and you know the sense of responsibility
and duty is so visible when you when
you're doing stuff within your network
now i started my january long time ago
like around machine learning classic and
physics about 10 years ago a bit before
the army i started to work for some
small startup company called the
powermat
something i led the research around
physics there
and i started there as a mathematician
physicist who started to simulate the
physical rules in order to
to improve some
uh electricity transfer platforms
uh from there i joined to the army to
to
help with the underground thunders
detection research
so
and in the army we did some more
advanced techniques than simply
simulating the physics around us we
started to use some machine learning so
you could see
how
people became a bit less of domain
expert because they used to you know
they needed only to
understand which feature were better and
which feature less and doesn't need it
to completely simulate the old physics
around them
um
after the army i joined a nuclear
research center
for as one does after the army yeah
this one that after the army well in
israel it's uh it's possible you
might work around and
underground unless detection got some
attentions um
so yeah i joined this nuclear research
center and we started to just to be i
started to be busy with unstructured
data which is a bit different problem
than everything else right you you don't
familiar with all the features that
constructing some space you have to
understand
how to extract this information
uh right and this is the first time i
heard about those neural networks which
is a whole process that that is
essentially a feature extractor uh model
that allow you to
to apply these mathematics models on
some unknown structure
uh what was what was it about neural
networks that so you see i mean
obviously you're a researcher
you're passionate about physics and
mathematics and and the space
but
you know as you're going through your
journey obviously you're identifying
things that are you're more or less
excited about and it sounds to me like
something about this unstructured nature
of of this work and neural networks
really got you hooked well what was it
about this space that got you so excited
yeah it's the applications like in the
end of the process when you want to
solve
genetic sequencing problems and you want
to find mutations in in data that you
have no idea how to access to
the only way you can
you can do it is with neural networks
like on when you want to apply you want
to solve autonomous vehicle or
text generation or everything that is
you know
used to be impossible to neural networks
you just enable all those different
technologies so
as you know from there from the diet of
scientists
eventually
out of nowhere you can busy with very
deep problems you can solve stuff that
weren't solvable until then
on top of that
and so what was it was was it exciting
to you from a from a from a mathematics
point of view or from a world-changing
point of view the fact that you can now
apply this to a variety of applications
that previously were not attainable
until now well the answer is both the
mass behind it it's amazing like the
people that work on those fields are
brilliant and the ideas and you know all
these
research is just incredible i
used to have a habit to read at least
one paper every morning and then so i
used to every morning and yeah the best
thing i could do for myself uh
so the mass is amazing and the
application is incredible and your
impact is is huge so
just exciting every day when you get to
work on those incredible um
me a little bit about the transition to
the startup world so you're working for
organizations
and a few years ago you decided to go on
on your own journey what was it about
sort of this this mission behind that
the mission that tensor leap is on
that got you really excited
yeah you know uh
when you
work in within all those different
uh development teams and developing
those cutting-edge technologies you
you get in a different perspective and
the way we used to develop machine
learning and ai
kind of
require the changing like
in the beginning like 2014
uh you could train 100 model in 10
minutes in and great search the model
that is working best for for each point
you could
tear apart each model to 100 pieces
understand completely how it works if
something something failed
you could work a bit and explain why it
failed now in your network they enable
so much but they're
they're so complex and so big
that it
became so hard to understand how they're
working and therefore so hard to
adapt those technologies now you see as
you see a technology that can transform
the old world can solve
you know can get us much much
much
far
forward with neural net with uh cancer
detection with cancer treatment with
autonomous vehicle and
uh
and still it's impossible to adapt it
because companies don't have the
confidence that required in order to
deploy to production because it's
impossible to test today in your network
they're huge in your network today
applying
on fields that there's too many edge
cases and each hks doesn't get enough
representation in this test set that
everyone managed to build so they're
building like 500 000 samples that set
and each edge case may be represented by
a few hundred or thousands of samples
they will never move the accuracy enough
in order to show the data science that
it failed so
you you get in
a very hard time
getting confidence on what you're gonna
deploy to production or explain how it
works so once it's getting to production
getting some prediction outside and your
users trying to ask okay so why you
think that this is the result it's gonna
be a huge problem to to explain how it
happened
so
right so what and what you're describing
here is sort of this this paradigm in
which we have a very unique opportunity
that neural networks present to us but
the the lack of explainability and
observability into understanding why
why something is as it is
um
you know there's only so much trust
there can be and and obviously as you
get to the more fine-grained question of
why did something behave the way that
this specific element behave
then it's getting a little bit more
more difficult and complex to to solve
so is that really the did i catch really
the main pain point that you're
describing here
yeah so you have two kinds of
explainabilities you have a local
explainability which is trying to
explain why neural network took decision
in a specific place like for example why
car crashed in a on that on the truck
that looks like a bridge
okay it's a locker it's a very specific
example and you have global
explainability when you're trying to
explain how your network perceives
reality in general like which cases
looks looks alike and what dimension
distributing the data sets and etc so
we're trying to solve both we have
a very unique technology that able to
extract the most relevant information
that the neural network managed to land
in the training process and distribute
all data set according that which allow
us to find all the
all the small use cases that
counted as edge case because they are
represented by very specific features
that not that common for example so
so give me maybe this can be better
explained through some some specific
examples of of how how different
problems in the world may benefit from
from sort of this
a solution to this pain point that
you're describing so what are some maybe
some
ideas for case studies that that this
would be relevant for yeah you know it's
it's also one of their reasons it's so
exciting to found and solid you can see
around us we have companies that helping
cancer treatment and they use the
platform and you see how they
advance they researched and how they
managed to
to overcome all their own expectation
with
this explainability they managed to
extract from the platform together with
other companies that's running on
autonomous vehicle and you've got to
feel that you're part of their project
right they're sharing with us the result
they're sharing you guys the
incredibles the incredible uh
use cases and and insights they managed
to get and you feel so
given you this sense of of duty and and
purpose which is amazing so what is
their interaction with so so maybe you
can share with me about you know what is
sort of their their research pipeline
and where does tensor leap interject
into the pipeline of the work that these
the this let's say this cancer
this cancer treatment company how
how how how does tensor leap integrate
into a pipeline like that sure so they
have a team of data scientists this time
team of data scientists need to collect
an asset out of data sets in order to in
their case uh detect very particular
mutations of cancer using liquid biopsy
so in liquid biopsy you have
uh
a lot of
dead cells in the blood some of them
belong to cancer
and it's a very
few some of them like 0.1
sorry how to detect it when you get in
billion of rates billion of different uh
gene sequences that you need to process
so what they do they need to
understand how to construct these
datasets from the right amount
of
gene sequences now unlike images and
voice and text stuff that people like us
are used to process
it's it's a black box for them they have
no idea which sample looks like another
like this gene of sequences looks in a
very particular way and another these
genes sequences looks in a very in a
different way but are they similar
we don't know to we can't see it with
our eyes so what they able to do is one
big training once the training in your
network just finding the features that
relevant to understand uh which
samples look like each other
they able to understand
how their data set is distributed and
what kind of samples they're missing and
one kind of what kind of samples they
have too much of and sometimes they so
they collecting these data sets starting
randomly and uh constructing some kind
of neural network that should be able to
extract the information from those
sequences
giving it the task of detecting uh
mutations very specific mutation did
they know how to
uh treat
uh and after the first
training of the neural network tensor
lip extracting within the development
process right all
the different features that
distributing the data set in this other
way and
notifying the developed data scientist
about edge cases that it found using the
features that land within the model
itself and by that they detecting they
detected for example a list of packs
they had in their own
data generation pipeline so that the lab
and the sequencing
blood tests and they detected that they
had a bug in a few areas that caused a
very big bias in this neural network now
they will never have any ability to
detect those stuff without applying very
deep explainability techniques
to analyze the features that land within
this neural network
so
we're sitting in those area where data
scientists trying to
improve these development cycles which
is constructing the dataset
error analysis and generating different
experiments to solve very specific
issues
and with testing
so before each time they need to deploy
a new model to production they need to
know if it's really solved several
issues and that
none of the new issues emerge into this
new model so
take me back to how
everything you just described about you
know um
about the way that you're empowering
researchers and data scientists within
these organizations do their better work
how does this tie into your own journey
and what you care about you started off
by talking about how excited you are
both on the mathematics but the
application layers of what all this
research is doing
going on to founding tensor leap how
does this feed into your own sort of
mission in life right now of what you
care about in the advancement of
research and the applications you know
uh
a bit
before i i found a tensor leap together
with my partners david anir i worked
with david in
autonomous vehicle company
and we developed those technologies and
it was
hard we needed to detect obstacles using
um
passive sensors
two kilometers from the target on dark
on fork on snow
uh with camera that's moving like crazy
so we applied you know list of pipeline
of neural network that was super
advanced
and
each time it got to production it got to
one of our clients it came back with
okay it works perfect except of this and
these days when
we think that the sun were in some area
in the sky
i don't know now i need to take it all
conduct experiments for months hope that
i guessed right and and give my client
confidence to use it again when i myself
terrified that it gonna fail
i'm using like i'm applying your network
on autonomous vehicles i might kill
people and you don't feel good with
yourself when you're doing that right
you don't have a lot of choice you get
paid and you're doing we did the best we
could we we did the best there is
outside right we use the cutting edge
technology i read every day a paper or
two
i i did everything we could no one did
better than us and in any benchmark but
still
when i deployed a model i couldn't sleep
it was terrible
and you just
just so hard to get confidence
on
the thing that matter when you have no
visibility towards how it's taking
decisions right now david used to came
to me and tell me the tom
is that really nothing to do like this
is the reality that we need to
to accept
and the answer is no i told him no of
course not but if you'll give me
let's say five or ten full stocks and
one and a half years i'll manage to
build some
mechanism that will allow us to extract
the features and the information we need
in order to query these neural networks
and after it happened for six months or
a year we decided to found tensorly
[Applause]
and that company using it today
uh i love it
that that is so cool you tom and i think
that i i just want to
constantly bring it back to sort of this
underlying mission you know tensor leap
is fantastic as an angel investor
obviously i'm i'm i'm very objective and
me saying that it's a fantastic company
but
you know i think the truth is that what
you're touching on is a problem that we
all need to be cognizant of and so it's
something that we all need to appreciate
and respond to
this underlying question fundamentally
how do we do research and how do we
advance technology
and these this is not you know child's
play we're not building these next games
that
are just entertainment and you know
these are literally life altering
technologies whether it be cancer
research to save lives or whether it be
different medicines to be administered
to people with and researching the side
effects or autonomous cars that yes
they're going to be taking over the
world and hopefully the right networks
are being used to train them and so i
think that what you're doing here above
all is is making sure that we have a
safer future
more resilient future with with
obviously better
results and more efficient research but
underlyingly
one that we control better because we
want to do good in the world whoever is
helping train the next neural network
system for autonomous cars
having that ability and observability
and explainability
will make it safer for all of us and yo
tom i really want to appreciate you for
this time and the energy for the great
work you're doing for tenserly but more
importantly for for for sharing this
this exact message that hopefully it got
right because it's a very inspiring one
so thank you very much
thank you thank you misshan it was great
to be hosted by this
yeah thank you